HE'S ALSCOURAGING TH
HAICAL NEEDS ARRANGEMENTS BEFOR
STORM HITS
W TOKR WHEREOTING
ARE TAKINGLA IANNDUMS ONFERER IA
OC TERRITOF
ESHE
ZE, E  TAY.TORING GROUP
NEAR 1
GEL N LYLSRMENVL PUTIN MILITARDR
SOWE'RE STUTE U.
PT
SO, DOEST REALLY HELRUSS
FI IRS I
THWH YOU'RE GOING U ON THE WHO M
T I WOULDN'TE ANT,LI A
THE POINT ISS
D DOWNHE'S GOINGO
TH
ITOT 300,0
IT'S UP TO AONAND THEI REPRESSN
WOULD ES IS
MAE  OVERTHROW
PUIFE IE EAR WEE,UTWAR IS TO GOG
OUR PROBLEM ISHAOT
VI UNIY O RUIAE
EINFORCEMENTS COME
IN.
R THINGS DO YOU
LIE THEY NEE>> WEL MON, LONGAN
MISSILES.
WHICH WE'VE BEENAL ABOUT ES KE
THERE. IS NOT
SO, THERE ARE MAFERENT
PODULATE WE'RE AFRAID THEY'LL O
THERE.HOULD ATT LY GOING TUCLIAR
IT O TELANS YOU HAVE
ETARY-RA ABOY INKRUR ANSWE NATO
THE BATTLEELD FURTSO
>> SO, IN YOIS G ON, HOW LG
PPND A
>> OH, INDTELY.NO QUESTION WE CE
F SUPPORT WHERE IT AMABLY.
HAR
INAL BASES MED ALITTLE MORE.
G 18 OF TSE
THFRTRIAL OULY LOVE TO G18 IF F
T THAT EXP.
HARDER TO BE AP THE THIS DER AN
THISS NO FORCES, AND WHAT T
SECRETAR SAYING,
E EFOR END UWITH AD NO
YEAR, THREE-
WI IILRUSSIAKEY WILL ANPNT FORC
RUSSIA CERLYE ATTACKS ON
THE GROUND FOR WIT T
THE QUESTION IS WHR
ACTU F TTHIS IS HE GROUNINRE
FIGHTING T DECISIONMAKING APPAR.
FACTIONS IEUSO, THERE ARE NYHAT?
D ITE EFFECTIVE?WE DON
AY
E TO INE NOW SO THEY CAN PUSHRU
BY THESHOULD CLEAR, NOT JUST THU
CLE TO GOUT,SION IS NOTED,
CARAEEE TO
SA.
WHOR NOT WE WANT TO
OR NEXT
VER,T'L STORDER.
SANCTIA